[Music]
from the moment on we decided to do this
project the next step was to actually
apply when we were writing the
application we always worked together i
think that was also a secret that i
would advise young people applying
because all of us actively at one room
at one place writing it helped us to
brainstorm to get good ideas to develop
good ideas maybe to change some parts
then to adjust some parts and feel each
other with some new information we
always sat together and the most
productive nights were the one with one
laptop and then the laptop just goes
from a lecture lap and we all shout in
ideas and it was always like this eating
having fun and i think it made us feel
like doing something and bringing
something new into this world
[Music]
when we were writing the application we
always brought it together was it online
was it together in person we had some
shared folders we had some sections we
had our gem boards our padlet boards we
tried to use everything that we could to
make the process of brainstorming and
putting parts together
from the application to copy it and have
some backup to share online then
sometimes also meet in person cook a
nice meal sit down at the couch in these
winter nights when we applied changed
the ideas from one to another into
developing into some of the new
workshops that we never started with in
the end we had the whole year because as
you know the solidarity project can be
two months or 12 months something in
between and we were like okay we will
apply for six months and in this process
of writing we had a lot of ideas so we
said no you know what let's try our best
and describe it for 12 months with some
exhibitions with some workshops and try
to put it so nicely together that we can
maybe get the whole year for our fashion
[Music]
what i would advise you if you have a
idea and you want to start it you want
to change it just start it's simple as
that sit down write with your own words
and don't try to be formal put it on the
paper and see how you can connect it do
a small technique of trying to find the
clues the problem tree or some other of
methods and you will really fast come up
to it and find your friends that's what
i advise do it with your friends because
you also need to have fun
[Music]